there's like people that do plant  medicine and then they they work on  people right what's plant medicine like  herbal well there's like Ayahuasca  there's like rape they don't go Bulova  not that  he turns off his brain and kind of just  lets his hands do the work like what is  he doing so when he's under medicine  like obviously you're in an altered  state of consciousness  oh your back is in pain  [Laughter]  hold up  can you get a large pizza yeah hang on  but anyway like that's his superpower he  takes whatever he needs to to become a  doctor or whatever it's not a doctor are  you tired you're tired okay his coffee  okay  are you sleeping okay hold on